with the president Secretary of Treasury
the president's congressional liaison
getting things done we Democrats are
trying to get things done not making
partisan speech after partisan speech
now in the past 24 hours we got word
that a member of this chamber Senator
Paul has tested positive for coronavirus
and the husband of another member
senator Klobuchar also tested positive
he's in the hospital I want to let them
know both of them that the Senate's
thinking of them praying for their
speedy recovery as we are for tens of
thousands of American families who are
confronting the same situation right now
whether you're afraid for a sick family
member and older relative in the
hospital or are struggling without work
income or the knowledge of when your
isolation might end our thoughts are
with you right now these are trying
times for all of us but the scourge of
this disease will pass the American
people as always will prevail as the
number of confirmed kovat 19 cases in
the United States eclipses 35,000 the
Senate continues to negotiate what will
likely be the largest emergency funding
bill in American history
as I've mentioned we've had almost
continuous discussions with secretary
minuchin he left my office at about
12:15 last night and was there at about
9:00 this morning the White House
congressional liaison Eric uhland has
been in out of the office as well we're
very close to reaching a deal very close
and our goal is to reach a deal today
and we're hopeful even confident that we
will meet that goal
we've been working on a few outstanding
issues that are no surprise to everyone
from the very beginning Democrats have
insisted on a Marshall Plan for our
medical system more money for hospitals
community health centers nursing homes
and urgent medical supplies like gloves
and masks ICU beds testing kits
ventilators and PPE P since our
negotiations the numbers have gone up
dramatically because the hospitals or
health care workers need the help
we're fighting hard and making progress
for funding for state and local
governments they're propping up local
health care networks virtually on their
own their revenues are dramatically
declining many towns and villages across
America the smaller ones in particular
might be going broke pretty soon if we
do nothing if we can help the big
corporations we can help our local towns
and villages and the taxpayers they
represent on unemployment insurance the
bill is moved in the direction we've
outlined the original bill had the
unexpanded employment benefits last only
three months we need to make it longer
because the dislocation caused by this
crisis will not be over in ninety days
and people who lose their jobs need help
but it says to every American who loses
his or her job the Democratic plan that
is now in the bill that you will get
your full pay from the federal
government you can be furloughed by your
employer that means you'll keep your
benefits health and otherwise and it
means that you'll be able to come back
and the business you had to leave we can
reassemble itself quickly after God
willing this crisis ends the bill still
includes something that most Americans
don't want to see large corporate
bailouts with know almost no strings
attached maybe the majority leader
thinks it's unfair to ask protections
for workers in labor to companies that
are getting hundreds of billions of
dollars we think it's very fair to ask
those those are not extraneous issues
that is a wish list for workers nobody
else and so we are looking for
protection we're looking for oversight
if this federal government's making a
big loan to someone it's a big company
we ought to know it and know the details
immediately the bill that was put on the
floor by the Republican leader said no
one would know a thing about those loans
for six months at least and in those
thing in those so called bailouts we
need to protect workers the workers
those industries employ employee we've
been guided by one plan workers first
that's the name of our proposal the bill
needs to reflect that priority now we're
working on all these items in good faith
as we speak and we hope and expect to
conclude negotiations today this vote in
the Senate is no surprise it's about
it's it's to take a merely repeat of the
boat vote that failed last night leader
McConnell continues to set arbitrary
vote deadlines when the matter of real
importance is the status of the
bipartisan negotiations so let me be
clear the upcoming procedural votes are
essentially irrelevant the negotiations
continue no more than 30 feet away from
the floor of the Senate in our offices
where the real progress is taking place
once we have an agreement that everyone
can get behind
we're prepared to speed up the
consideration of that agreement on the
floor so I'm gonna get back to
negotiations we all know time is of the
essence the country is facing the twin
crises in our health care system and in
our economy we have an obligation to get
the details right get them done quickly
that doesn't mean blindly accepting a
Republican only bill that was the bill
we were given lots of things we didn't
even know about
Saturday that means working to make this
bill better better for our small
businesses better for our working
families better for our healthcare
system
Democrats Democrats will not stop
working with our Republican counterparts
until we get the job done I'll continue
to update the presenteth on the progress
of our negotiations and I note the
absence of a quorum